[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
bevor ich das letzte mal nach österreich
gereist bin habe ich die kleine umfrage
gemacht und gesagt was soll ich in
österreich unbedingt kaufen was gibt es
in deutschland nicht und ich glaube 80
prozent meiner zuschauer haben
geschrieben
steirisches kürbiskernöl also bin ich
zum nächsten interspar markt gefahren
habe das kürbiskernöl gekauft und
natürlich zu hause gleich probiert ich
muss sagen und ich glaube so geht es
vielen von euch ich kenne das
kürbiskernöl nur als verfeinerung über
die kürbissuppe
da gibt man es einfach oben drauf das
gibt eine schöne farbe und macht einfach
nochmal einen tollen geschmack aber
viele österreichische und auch deutsche
zuschauer haben geschrieben sally du
musst unbedingt mal kürbiskernöl auf eis
probieren auf vanilleeis und ich hab mir
gedacht
vanille eis schmeckt bestimmt gar nicht
aber wir werden es gleich ausprobieren
ich habe zu ihr das kürbiskernöl das ist
wirklich original aus der steiermark und
ich zeige euch einfach mal wie das
aussieht
ich habe ich einen weißen teller und ich
finde kürbiskernöl ist wirklich so möhl
was extrem anders und total interessant
aussieht hat mir ziemlich dunkle farbe
sieht leicht braun aus aber wenn man ein
stückchen brot nimmt und dass ein punkt
dann sieht man dass es so richtig kürbis
camp grün ist vom geruch her auch
ziemlich lecker und ich habe es jetzt
auch schon als salat dressing versucht
mit einfach ein bisschen essig verfallen
hat über den salat gegeben und ich finde
das macht den salat einfach noch ein
bisschen knackiger und frischer und
verleitung salat eine schöne farbe und
natürlich einen tollen geschmack
jetzt probieren wir das kürbiskernöl mal
auf dem vanilleeis gab es bisher noch
nicht probiert und ich bin gespannt ob
es mir auch schmeckt
[Musik]
ich bin gespannt
also ist seht gewöhnungsbedürftig aus
weiß halt einfach grün ist aber ich kann
es mir glaube ich ganz gut so wenn
details vorstellen
superlecker also ich finde ja jede
eisdiele sollte auf jeden fall
steirisches kürbiskernöl verwenden als
topping für vanille 1 also richtig gut
solltet ihr auf jeden fall mal
ausprobieren und vielen dank nochmal für
die info kürbiskernöl hat die
besonderheit dass es zu 80 prozent aus
ungesättigten fettsäuren besteht es hat
kein cholesterin im gegensatz zu
tierischem fett zum beispiel und einem
sehr hohen vitamingehalt da stellt sich
die frage ob dieses vanilleeis es ein
gesundes eis ist nein ist es nicht aber
das öl ist gesund ich zeige euch jetzt
wie man aus dem kürbiskernöl noch ein
richtig leckeres pastor herstellen kann
das kürbiskernöl pesto verwende ich
kürbiskernöl basilikum kürbiskerne
knoblauch parmesan salz und pfeffer
jetzt ist im prinzip die zubereitung
ganz einfach die genauen rezepte und
zutaten gibt es auf meinem blog
jetzt will ich erstmal der parmesan
geräten
kommen die kürbiskerne in den mixer
knoblauchzehe dazu und jetzt kann ich
die zutaten alle miteinander verbinden
hier können jetzt noch der parmesan dazu
salz pfeffer und natürlich das
kürbiskernöl
was stelle ich die basilikumblätter
vergessen aber die kommen auch noch mit
rein
so sieht es pastor jetzt aus und das
kann ich jetzt zum beispiel auf
geröstetes brot geben und dann einfach
probieren
ich habe es eben schon probiert wenn ich
jetzt probieren kann ich nicht mehr in
die kamera lachen weil haben gesehen
wahrscheinlich grün und gelb sind aber
es ist einfach total lustig und
aromatisch kürbiskernöl ist ein
naturbelassenes produkt und wenn man da
auf die gute qualität achtet beim kauf
dann hat man wirklich noch alle
wichtigen spurenelemente inhaltsstoffe
und nährstoffe mit dabei hier beim öl
habe ich den vorteil ich kann hier auf
den qr-code gehen und das machen wir
jetzt mal denn so kann ich
herausbekommen wo das öl eigentlich
herkommen
[Musik]
ich habe hier die kontrolle eingegeben
und sehe woher die kürbiskerne stammen
die sind jetzt beim bauern peter und
kamen dann direkt so firma kindler und
da fahren wir jetzt mal hin und schauen
uns an wie das kürbiskernöl gepresst
wird also packt eure sachen zusammen es
geht nach österreich
[Musik]
anfang mai werden die kürbisse in der
steiermark gesät nach ein bis zwei
wochen schauen dann die zweiblättrige
pflanzen aus der erde im juni sieht man
auf den feldern dann die gelb
leuchtenden blüten
zwei monate später liegen dann die
gelb-grünen kürbisse auf den feldern im
september und oktober werden dann die
kürbiskerne herausgenommen oder aus
gebastelt so nennt man das herauslösen
der kerne aus dem fruchtfleisch
die bauern sollen dank ich kenne und
liefern sie an die firma kindler hose
zum beispiel der ullrich entgegen nimmt
hierbei kinder werden dann im spätjahr
die kürbiskerne angeliefert und dann das
kürbiskernöl produziert und ich dachte
ja immer das kürbiskernöl nur einmal im
jahr produziert wird eben dann wenn der
kürbis auch geerntet wird aber das ist
gar nicht so die kürbiskerne könnt ihr
nämlich gelagert werden ohne
qualitätsverlust und so kann das ganze
jahr über ganz frisches kürbiskernöl
produziert werden jetzt gehen noch mal
rein
deswegen habe ich übrigens auch dieser
schutzkleidung an die hygiene kleidung
denn wir gehen jetzt in die produktion
ist nicht der neueste trend
normalerweise werden natürlich die
großen mengen draußen angeliefert dem
lkw aber es gibt auch bauern die haben
einfach kleinere mengen und auch die
haben die möglichkeit hier ihre
kürbiskerne abzugeben und das passiert
dann durch den schacht
damit wirklich qualitativ hochwertiges
kürbiskernöl hergestellt werden kann
werden die kürbiskerne noch einmal
gereinigt das heißt alle bestandteile
die nicht hineingehören kommen raus dazu
gehören zum beispiel auch kaputter
kürbiskerne die können nämlich ranzig
werden weil er wirklich so viel fett
darin enthalten ist
ich habe ich mal die übrigen abverlangt
was dann übrig bleibt seht ihr hier
hinter mir die ganzen container sind
voll mit kürbiskernen die hier gelagert
werden in einen container passt ungefähr
eine tonne kürbiskerne und an der
aufschrift erkennen und dann auch von
wem die kürbiskerne stammen und somit
ist die produktionskette immer
transparenz die zwei sich zwar wurde
kürbiskerne gelagert werden aber ich
weiß immer noch nicht wie das
kürbiskernöl hergestellt wird also mache
ich mich jetzt mal auf die suche nach
modrig der weist nämlich gute nachricht
hatte ullrich gefunden
hier ist ulrich und mit seiner familie
in der zwölften generation hier seit 16
96 fast sich jung gehalten
ja und ihr seid ja die einzigen die
wirklich die kürbiskerne nur aus der
steiermark nehmen die aus dem ausland
importieren und das macht euer
kürbiskernöl aus genau wir arbeiten
neben mit den bauern und den landwirten
in der region zusammen wir schauen als
familienunternehmen das leben schon so
eine lange tradition hat dass wir die
wertschöpfungskette in der region halten
um das den globus arbeiten wir mit den
bauern aus der steiermark gemeinsam und
die wertschöpfungskette dieser wegen
nach nachverfolgbar das heißt auch ein
produkt gibt es einen qr-code und da
kann man nach erfolgen welcher bauer hat
diese kürbiskerne geliefert und so
wirklich richtig toll
die kerne kommen aus dem lager zum
vordersten und werden dort vor
temperiert so setzen sie auch schon
langsam das öl frei was ich faszinierend
finde olivenöl zum beispiel muss er dann
gepresst werden wenn die ernte ist mit
kürbiskernöl könnt ihr das material
gefressen
die kürbisse werden demnach der ernte
getrocknet und nun auf sechs bis acht
prozent eher um dadurch sind sie sehr
lange lagerfähig sprich bei uns läuft
die produktion das ganze jahr aber die
warenannahme ist nur einmal in aktion
und da hat man immer frisches gewiss
kabine der schock nach der röstung geht
es weiter
[Musik]
die kürbiskerne werden in feinem mehl zu
mahlen und mit wasser und salz fermate
damit sich das fett vom kern trend der
vorteil vom wasser ist auch dass die
roest massa nicht verbrennt man rechnen
4 s dauer und die temperatur sind ein
betriebsgeheimnis und der ölpreis
meister
er stellt über den geruch und die farbe
fest ob die roest masse ausreichend
gerüstet ist hier ist also das
fingerspitzengefühl und die jahrelange
erfahrung des prez meisters besonders
wichtig den beruf des ölpreises gibt es
übrigens nur in österreich in das bayer
machen
[Musik]
nehmen sie die fertige ross voraus sie
haben natürlich jahrelange erfahrungen
wissen wann der perfekte zeitpunkt ist
und jetzt gehen wir schon rüber zu den
treffen
[Musik]
der film transportiert jetzt den rest
machen in die presse ein und der
unterschied zum beispiel zu anderen öl
ist das hier ein stempel presse
verwendet wird es gibt auch eine
schnecken presse die dann wirklich durch
eine schnecke zum beispiel beim olivenöl
das öl gepresst dadurch entsteht aber
auch nochmal reibung und beschreibung
entsteht wärme und dadurch wird eben die
ganze rest massa noch mal geröstet
werden und so kann man dann die
temperatur nicht mehr kontrollieren also
gibt's hier die stempel presse was in am
rand ganz will sich kleine löcher und da
tritt dann das öl aus und der rest das
zeige ich euch jetzt mal was geführt
[Musik]
hier hinten wir dann das öl gesammelt
und kommt dann in den tank auf
[Musik]
die schwebstoffe sinken dann zu boden
das öl wird abgesaugt und in flaschen
abgefüllt der press korreliert ist es
kein abfall sondern wurde früher einfach
als tierfutter verwendet was früher als
tierfutter verwendet wurde wird heute
zum beispiel in der veganen küche
eingesetzt einfach als ersatz für mail
es hat zwar keine back eigenschaft aber
es ist zum beispiel eine alternativ
verwirklichen mail und wirklich ähnlich
in der verarbeitung den kurven nehmen
wir mal für den mut hatten mit verliebt
doch die vegane küche hat die führung
gefallen
aber wer ist wir sind sehr alt geständig
das familienunternehmen dass die habe
ich die ganze familie zusammen gebracht
und wir werden jetzt unsere produkte
kosten das ist etwas woran ich ja was
für dich dabei futter für die mutter ja
also dann probieren nochmals und ihr
dürft einfach ist es zu schauen und
nicht tragbar schweigt wichtig ist dass
das steirische kürbiskernöl auf jeden
fall trocken vor licht geschützt und
kühl gelagert wird
und so ist es dann neun bis zwölf monate
haltbar aber auch hier gilt je frischer
umso besser
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ein richtiges problem dar
das kürbiskernöl kann in der kalten und
auch in der warmen küche verwendet
werden
aber man sollte es nicht zu stark
erhitzen den dann entsteht ein
unangenehmer geruch und die wertvollen
inhaltsstoffe werden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenn jetzt schon lecker gegessen jetzt
sitzen wir gleich noch ein bisschen
gemütlich zusammen für euch gibt jetzt
aber schon einige wind trage sie stellte
hose genau wann gibt es unser
familienunternehmen und warum hält er so
jung
beantwortet einfach die frage und dann
verlosen wir dieses geschenk paket das
gibt es dann gleich drei mal schreibt
einfach die richtige antwort unten in
die kommentare
und der gewinner wird per los gezogen
dankeschön
[Musik]
meine reise geht weiter aus der
steiermark direkt an den neusiedler see
dort werde ich einfach gleich münchen
besuchen
[Musik]